can we talk about Last of Us for right
now did you guys like the episode I did
like the episode I'm I was wondering if
you liked it well I played the video
game so I know what happens okay so
what happens in the show you get killed
ten times
the guy just runs into the wall and goes
where are the zombies okay
over and over for hours
bro he's hiding behind the [__] thing
and jeffy's the bad guy and he pops up
boom hits his partner in the head
shoots the little girl that he's
fighting against you can't shoot her
throws the controller and goes too many
buttons
too many buttons too many buttons I quit
playing video games as soon as he had to
use two joysticks I was like I'm done
joysticks it's a lot of work it's too
much it's too much a lot it's all
because you got to understand I went
from I guess PlayStation had two son we
started with Nintendo two buttons
of times but simpler it was simpler time
bro your girl did some ice cold [__] to
you also do you remember this no it's
just so funny we come back from [__]
wherever during the day and then the X
the PS5 is set up perfectly ready to go
and it's right before he's about to
leave and then he's like oh man I cannot
wait we're gonna go home we're gonna get
two more hours and I'm gonna get Ellie
to the bridge and then we're gonna get
the vaccine made blah blah he's like
planning out the whole day in the car
talking with everyone about what he's
gonna do in the game and she goes you're
a dork bro he's hyped I'm fired up too
I'm like all right show time opens the
door the whole house spotless PS5 put in
the car and it was in the car the whole
time he goes ah and then looks at her
and she goes
literally hit her with the Michael
Jordan it was in the car the whole time
so the whole time you're talking about
it she heard me talk about it the whole
time
single [__] words just sitting there
driving chuckling to herself she was
amazing disappointed man she has to
drive no she don't know she don't like
it when I drive well you don't pay
enough attention she can still be mad
yeah I don't either that's gonna be
driving no no she likes to drive it's
literally like her thing she's really
into it oh God bless dude yeah and I
like it that she drives but I can't tell
her that too much because then it'll
take away from her and she always has to
feel she's getting a little over me on
the driving yeah you're gonna drive and
then she said yeah can I just hit it
fine I don't ever want to drive again
Smart in my life yeah but you can't tell
them that if you tell them because then
it ruins the whole thing you learn how
to handle that from dealing with Dove
yeah of course you got to make them feel
like oh negotiation you know okay so
back to this last of us thing I I first
of all the show is [__] phenomenal
um
yeah it's just it's just excellent
it's just excellent I love the world I
love what they [__] built and I and
I'm this specific episode
[__] everybody bro if I got the vaccine
in me or whatever and I pull up to a
town that like that old Jackson Hole you
got electricity you have food you got a
movie theater you got everything yeah
yeah yeah and then I'm leaving to go to
Salt Lake City for a maybe no yeah I
know I didn't like that I'm pulling Joel
aside I'm like yo [__] these
[__] we got it yeah we're good
we can't develop it here pull in some
scientists literally that's what I
thought I was like yo send somebody down
a Salt Lake bring them back up here and
let's see if we can science this [__] up
but I'm not moving bro somebody else
brought up a good point if you're the
episode before they drive through Kansas
City or two episodes before it why are
we driving through urban areas what good
can come from that there gotta be a way
they don't want to drive through the
urban area is there no other way well in
the episode they pull up and there was a
block on the highway so the idea why
they went okay we'll just Veer out and
then get right back on because they know
that urban areas is where the function
is
they thought about that [__] Kansas City
doesn't look good about everything they
do it doesn't look that different look
now yeah yeah it looks weirdly similar
yeah yeah
it didn't touch them that bad yeah I
don't know it was just it was just yeah
I just I saw that I saw how I love how
people kind of recreate Society I think
it's really exciting and I'm like this
is great you guys [__] did it you
don't have to say a single word to
anybody or you could say it tell them
listen I got the vax I can't die I'm not
moving
you either kill me and nobody get
vaccinated or you go find some [__]
scientist oh yeah yeah that's a great
time you got all the cards 100 I didn't
think about that so I'm just yeah that
was the one thing that just drove me
[__] crazy about it because it's dumb
to send the [__] possible vaccine out
there in danger yeah
like there's a bunch of scientists that
can be science and there's only one
person that can be and she's protected
right now by a full ass 14. no I will
say this now I'm gonna make the argument
for the uh the town which is if they go
tell another town or a a revolutionary
group hey we have the vaccine over here
and we happen to have a town with a
movie theater and electricity because
there's a dam by the river and we have
food for everybody and then hunting and
it's fortified they're gonna go whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa I'm sick of
being in [__] Kansas City or Salt
Lake or whatever these dumps that
they're staying in we're going we're
taking over that [__] town and it's
game over everybody yeah so you got to
be tight on it good point you can't just
let everybody know another thing I just
thought of he says to his brother Joel
says to his brother Texas dying wish
so I think he's doing it a lot to honor
her yeah and not just keeping her bad I
said I'd get her to these [__]
fireflies I don't even know so good
about these people yeah I'm gonna get
her to these fireflies I was her dying
wish I have to honor that yeah and that
[__] is dead bro
they didn't play with that relationship
enough that is true the tests and Joel
relationships yeah because it kind of
seems early on like this is a great
point because it kind of seems like
she's kind of almost like a side chick
yeah kind of like he's not fully in love
with her he's not fully in a
relationship it's a very tricky thing I
think that's a good point and in the
game they don't play it up at all I
asked what happens in part two because I
didn't want to buy the game because I'd
just be so addicted yeah so son I I I
have to actually limit myself who did
you ask you could make so much money
streaming video games it's still crazy
to me but I should do that [__] yeah
because that's entertaining you want to
wait that video game yes
yes I don't remember how Martin you play
video games like like you can't like
movies yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's the beginning of the game there's
no zombies at all the girl wakes up
there's [__] explosions on the TV the
apocalypse is happening she walks
downstairs and he's just watching the
cut scene just like sitting here just
like eating chips and then all of a
sudden Joel busts into the room and he
goes oh
there's no zombies it was the good guy
that came in it wasn't even a bad guy
but the way he busts it in it's like fam
like it's like it's a global apocalypse
right now
oh [__] God damn Joel yeah I did I
didn't I screamed at the movie part I
wasn't even playing the game suck you in
it's one of the greatest games ever
again an animated now imagine you
watching me watch that now imagine
you're watching me watch that wouldn't
that be entertaining
son because I get too addicted to the
games bro yeah but it would be work at
that point yes I'm gonna be working till
four in the morning
I'm different about it like I'm for real
okay yo okay no I'm I'm for real bro
it's it's different than y'all you say
that like it's not embarrassing the way
I get it like I grow up like y'all grew
up you know what I mean like the way I
game is different like I'm being I'm
being for real like I don't do the
things you do you and I are not the same
yeah
are you googling the answer soft support
got the magazine with all the answers
next to you probably while you game
the first bit of like difficulty getting
through the board oh what should I look
for that's the character
istics
it was crazy it's the [__] you bought
you put a cartridge in it and then you
put the game in the [__] cartridge
and then it just unlocked
you can play Mario with like a hundred
lives it was amazing yeah did you just
buy it in a store or you've had like had
no someone [__] else would you buy the
guy I ordered online was it like a deep
cut like Chinese
he's asking [__] I'm not [__] Native
American was it at every game
look all you gotta do is get them
titties
what's going on over here son don't do
that
yes we bought the [__] games
GameStop no yeah but it came out like
1990-91 so we were like kids so it was
the coolest thing don't placate his
insults yeah okay you're right you know
what I'm saying he's asking anything
yeah yeah you do that are you like from
Sears you like got the Sears catalog and
ordered it or what
just let him sit man honest question
what'd you guys do
what
how did you get this thing
you know to forge it
we got a fortune
mining for supplies
or no
[Laughter]
um oh you know I think the show also
does really well pacing like this
episode you're kind of like nothing is
happening I get they found this to and
then at the end you're like oh [__] that
just went crazy and I was thinking about
it even with uh I think an episode or
two before that with the puns how they
spaced the puns out long enough that you
kind of forget about it and then you
laugh every time yeah and then they
brought it back again in this episode I
feel like this show really is incredible
incredibly well paced yeah and I feel
like that sets it apart from a lot of
other good shows yeah and that's what
makes it great now they know what
they're doing man like the show is
already great source material and then
the dude who adapted it is the guy that
did Chernobyl oh I need to see Chernobyl
that's far so it's like
I want to get them on a pod by the way I
would love that that would be fire but
uh but yeah so it's like you have dope
Source material it's like put it this
way if you're someone who does Chernobyl
you don't take a I'm assuming you don't
take a video game story and make it into
something unless it's Flames if it's
just some Shoot Em Up [__] like when we
were young Doom or whatever like
don't care about the story whatever but
if if you look at that and you go oh my
God this is you know how one of the
highest grossing video games ever and
the story's kind of fire yeah and HBO
wants to run it
yeah and that girl in it is fire she's
fantastic dude she's [__] good she's
fantastic
do you think they'd do this with more
video games they just started taking
games that have like a decent storyline
they're like run it even if it's not HBO
if it's like any other story or or I
think they'll do it because Hollywood is
in like a race to be second so
everybody's gonna try to take the video
game franchise but this is what I think
will happen when you see the
profitability of a great storyline
injecting a video game not only for the
game itself but also at as as like as a
financial property turned into like a
scripted franchise you'll start going oh
we need to invest in the story part of
this [__] like somebody told me about
this game called Red Dead Redemption I
guess in Red Dead Redemption 2 and like
just a couple of games have good story I
haven't seen it I haven't played it but
I've obviously seen people doing it you
played it yeah yeah that's fun guys
played it yeah and was the story
compelling like this or was it not as
good as this okay yeah and like the
earlier ones like Red Dead Revolver it's
just like kind of just cowboys they were
able to do it with I didn't play the
games but it seems like even lesser
story lines like um Resident Evil they
did that was the game storyline fire
though or was it just like kind of cool
I think it was actually cool yeah the
game the the game storyline was like
interesting enough but there were enough
like challenges to keep you going I
remember the the Silent Hill do you guys
remember that game oh okay that one felt
like there was actually story you were
trying to like get to the bottom of
something yeah and then did they make
that into movie maybe they might have
did some of the songs if not that's
that's right there ready to go Resident
Evil they made [__] 16 movies Tomb
Raider they had movies about multiple
movies coming out with Uncharted
Uncharted Uncharted he's a movie it is
I think the same creative director or
game director as The Last of Us
struckman yes is uh yeah yeah they made
Silent Hill the movie they did yeah yeah
yeah I think Halo they made a show out
of Halo after yeah Halo was a game first
then books in the show yo it's almost
like
the Video Game World makes more money
than Hollywood right I wonder if you
have a really compelling story and
you're a kid that grew up playing video
games like think about the next
generation of like writers it's the
medium
yeah isn't that interesting like you you
could if you're if you're a writer uh oh
you're right or our age you're going I
want to write a movie or I want to write
a TV show I want to write a scripted
something right if you're a writer
that's maybe like late 20s you came up
with all these like amazing scripted
video games a meta kid recently that
said this exact thing he's like he's in
school right now he's at like scat I
think in Georgia and he's like yeah I'm
going he's like I'm a writer now the
Savannah College of Art and Designs yeah
he's going for specifically yeah for an
art degree and I was like oh what are
you in school for and he's like I'm a
writer and I was like oh what do you
want to write he goes Movie game or like
video game Scripts and I was like oh so
I'm not filming TV he's like nah
eventually it'll get there but think
about that like yeah and I think that's
where we'll go as these things are more
impactful to kids lives than actual
scripted shows and if you think you're
spending 10 hours 12 hours in one of
these worlds
it doesn't matter how good the TV show
you watch is if you're not spending that
much time yeah I mean it feels go no you
said uh video games are making more than
Hollywood I think the video game
industry is making more money than
Hollywood I could believe it just based
off how many video games are on how many
video game mediums there are but but
radically higher in video games as well
what was that cassetta the budgets are
oh wow yeah it seems like after covet it
took it over interesting well that makes
sense because they were making way less
so like the budget for a video game is
higher than like the budget for an
Avengers movie I can't be yeah that's
hundreds of millions of dollars it's
similar yeah budgets for big games like
Call of Duty or half a billion dollars
holy [__] I mean it's massive budgets
and what's the other one called uh Grand
Theft Auto yeah Rockstar yeah uh mobile
games they make the most money which is
also makes perfect sense but it's
hilarious yeah 93 billion off mobile
games I is 350 billion off console and
then 37 off I can't say 36 the third
largest uh 50 million game producer or
game uh uh place that you would play
them as Apple this year for the first
time because of like phones and they
have apple arcade bigger than Nintendo
oh you're saying the system that you use
it used to be it used to be Nintendo
Sony Microsoft computer all that kind of
stuff and Apple's just like running up
the thing because of mobile because
those aren't story based I just think
it's really cool like if I'm a kid and I
grew up watching Last of Us and I and I
like grew up playing it
yeah I mean I I'd go wow this is so cool
that I get to be the star yeah how many
hours invested like how many hours have
you watched last of us so far like six
six hours yeah and how many hours do you
spend playing the game I mean I don't
know how long it's that's it's not too
long games so but let's just say 12 14
or something like that 20 yeah yeah it's
probably like 20 24. yeah so it's like
you already doubled it and now you're
like all right I can play the next one
and think about how the viewing was it
was active viewing it wasn't passive
that's right you're locked in like think
about you're solving these things yeah
oh lastly and lastly
playing the game
versus another time kill which as I say
scrolling the internet when I scroll the
internet I'm sad afterwards yeah I'm
comparing myself to all these people
that are doing like way cooler things
for me than in that moment specifically
it seems like everybody's having you
know so much [__] they're just
throwing money all over the world right
and I'm thinking about like what I'm not
doing yeah when I play a video game
which is an equal waste of time when I'm
done I feel like I accomplished
something you feel great I was actually
scared of the feeling I had because I
was like I just wasted four hours and I
feel confident do you remember the first
video game we beat like a game like that
I'd be Jack and Daxter you ever played
that game I was actually made by the
same company I think it was naughty dog
but like I remember beating it as like
an eight-year-old and I cried when the
game played like the final role because
you didn't have more to play because I
was like a sense of accomplishment yeah
because I was like oh I finished it like
it's done like the characters are gone
like I can't be them anymore it was like
finishing a book or something I don't
know it was a weird I was like a kid and
I remember like crying as like it ended
I was like whoa yeah your Escape is gone
it's not out laughing at you so long
[Music]
it was with my friend it was the Ninja
Turtles video game but then we also had
we had a code for like nine lives
instead of three like you didn't cry
when you finish pong Al when you played
that game you were like oh man it's so
sad this is actual laugh
but yeah dude I remember finishing it
that game was the first one I think
naughty dog does all like the really
good narrative games the guy truckman
worked on one of I don't know if it's
that one he worked on one of those Jack
and Dexter games I think Jack three so
it's interesting that's full circle yeah
exactly yeah yeah I mean it's a skill
and now the graphics are good enough to
really like
to create the story because a lot of the
story is is essentially a movie like the
thing I got scared at wasn't me playing
right it was like they're actual actors
that they then turn into video game
characters when jokes aside when you're
watching a movie that kind of [__]
scares you if it's a scary movie
someone's bursting into a door but how
weird is it that you're taking real life
actors and then you're video gamifying
them like this is an animation I think
that they're doing all the dots like the
NBA 2K oh so they're shooting a movie
they've could be real
on there morphing it into a video game
yeah
that's wild
at a certain point it's just gonna be
actual actors like it's just gonna be
like I'm pretty sure that this the
acting scenes in this are played by real
actors yeah it's performance capture
motion capture on green screen and
everything yeah there's a green screen
oh really they're doing it and actually
capture it's just capturing their
movements performance captures what
Avatar is pushing it's like tracking
their actual facial performance and
everything Less on the animators but
motion captures the old technology that
are used in these games I mean it's just
dots and they recreate everything in the
in the in the Box you know what else
when you think about how into the games
we're getting it's going to be virtual
reality at some point yeah and then
think how like you're living in this
world than watching it on a movie it's
gonna be that much better once they make
it like yeah you're gonna live the
[__] thing yeah the storyline's gonna
become that much more important yeah I'm
curious if it goes virtual like if it
goes like headsets and [__] I assume a
shooter game will be so sick virtual
yeah I don't know I don't know if it
will so here's the reason why fun to
play they're just still kind of heavy
and
I assume that they can make it really
comfortable
there is a thing that will be
potentially limiting about it and that
is like and it's not with all games
because certain games are what is it
called first person shooter where you're
looking as if you have the goggles on
right I assume this was less yes well no
this one you're seeing your character
person third person okay which I like
because there's more of the world that
you get to observe so it's not it's you
but you're also observing everything
around you right and I think there's
more opportunities to like scare the
[__] out of somebody there's more
opportunities to like plan on how you
would get out of a situation
you create more of the world yeah you
know
um and it separates you a little bit but
uh but yeah I don't know maybe maybe it
just becomes that I don't know how many
games are still first person shooter the
last video game like this I'd be was
golden Knight so yeah who the [__] knows
it's golden hours fire so fire still
fire see yeah and then you brought this
thing about streaming like playing video
games at an arcade is kind of like
streaming oh yeah like everyone's
sitting around watching someone play so
when we were playing right and like and
obviously I was playing so everybody was
really entertained and watching and
loving it the the no no there was like
three of us that were playing it was me
Mark and Nick right and and we were just
playing and it was really fun to even
watch your buddy play and I started to
remembering back to when we would play
video games like we would play like
Street Fighter at the arcade and there
would be like six people watching and be
like one-on-one whatever you'd have your
quarter set up on the arcade that means
you had next and I'm like oh yeah the
streaming video game thing isn't new
we've just always played video games
with people yeah it's that is how
they've always been played yeah but now
it's so weird where it's like people are
playing alone and you're just watching
someone else play you don't want
everybody to play with them yeah there's
no quarter on the arcade yeah what I
would say is that's still enjoyable it's
just we never had a scenario where you
could do that and to me it looks stupid
I'm like wait they watch people play
video games what's the point of that but
when I was watching Mark beat the level
it was really fun yeah you know what I
mean and then but I think it's also
because you're right there in the room
with them you can talk to him you like
what you can chat on stream you're
beating the game together oh yeah well
that's exactly so that's what I'm saying
like let's say I am playing a game and
I'm walking to the walls and doing all
this other [__] if dudes are on stream
they're telling me Schultz look above
that box there's a thing that you need
so you're interacting with all these
people I don't know it's something that
looks so stupid to me like people
watching other people play video games
like I didn't understand it all of a
sudden made sense when I saw how fun it
was for all of us to just me dying over
and over again in the simplest things
and these guys are [__] cracking up
and he's just being horrible it's fun
yeah yeah that's awesome thank you guys
for watching that exclusive clip from
our patreon episodes you could join the
[__] Army at patreon.com
flagrant we have a new episode that
comes out every single Friday plus all
of our back catalog episodes go join
right now peace